[Music]
she admits the method of her appeal is
embarrassing but Tracy Hanson is
desperate for somebody to tell the
police where to find the fugitive wanted
for her son's murder is demeaning the
last thing anyone would want to do
especially the mother who's grieving her
child is to walk around with a man the
police would like to speak to in
connection of his mother on her chest
it's very painful it's very
uncomfortable for me he's been helped
just come forward even anonymously you
even have to leave your name just do the
right thing now help me no please Josh
Hanson was 21 when he was attacked and
stabbed in the neck for no apparent
reason he bled to death
it happened at a wine bar near his North
London home his attacker fled the scene
and went abroad Shane O'Brien is the man
detectives believe as the killer he's on
the run
thought to be in Europe but there are
reports - of him in Dubai it's likely he
still has this new distinctive tattoo on
his back one theory is the suspect is
being protected by members of an
organized crime group when he left the
UK he went by private jet whoever is
supporting him that tight group they are
providing him with money they are
providing him with the support and false
identification but we need one person to
make that call someone within the group
or on the periphery a year ago O'Brien
was arrested in Prague for assault he
was posing as an Italian with false
documents - official embarrassment
the suspect was freed on bail and
vanished there's a European arrest
warrant out for Shane O'Brien and he's
on Interpol's list of the world's most
wanted and there's a 50,000 pound reward
for information that leads to his arrest
and prosecution Josh's mom and his
sister Brooke will continue to appeal
for the public's help to stop they said
would be to let him down
martin brunt Sky News central London